welcome back everybody it's time to say
goodbye soon but we have a little time
left and i'd like to open up the floor
to our virtual friends
and this is the chance if you want to
ask me anything i'd be so happy to
answer you
katie do you have a question i do
hi drew i'm so excited to be here oh
thank you katie for coming on the show
okay so if we can get hypothetical for a
moment i want to know
if you weren't drew barrymore world
superstar talk show host what would you
be doing
you know um thank you for seeing me that
way i of course see myself as you know a
weird court jester
um but i always said that i would be a
travel writer um
i it's just been my dream job to work in
a magazine and get sent out an
assignment
and in my fantasy i'm also the
photographer i'm a one-man band and i
can do it all
and i get to see the world and
experience everyone else's life and
culture
and nature and metropolises and
i soak it all up and i learn everything
there is to learn
oh that's so cool that would be great i
could see you doing that thank you for
asking me that question now i'm in my
fantasy i hope you guys are
happy where you are think about all your
dreams and
just sit in them and feel good
and know that dreams can take us
anywhere even if we're right here
please have a safe wonderful rest of
your day and we'll see you here soon
hopefully
thank you so much
you